on considère que les territoires
autochtones représentent environ 20% de
la superficie totale de la planète
pourtant encore aujourd'hui des
décisions liées au développement de ces
territoires ou même à leur protection
sont prises sans jamais consulter les
peuples qui y vivent
mais le vent tourne et le savoir
autochtone est de plus en plus pris en
compte notamment par des scientifiques
qui veulent protéger le caribou
forestier une espèce en déclin
[Musique]
bon match et on est à chassagne de
naissance jeu tout a appris sur le
terrain sur le territoire nous voilà
quand on est sur le terrain avec
quelqu'un comme cela était tout est
facile aussi
[Musique]
tout ce que j'apprends à voir forum je
le partage c'est sur le lino ifo qui
partage son savoir le bateau ivre nous
sommes un pessimiste sur la côte nord on
va mettre à jour le drone des experts en
imagerie aérienne une ingénieure
forestières et des membres de la
communauté in où se rencontrent pour
mettre en commun leurs connaissances
avec votre expertise
l'objectif protéger le caribou des bois
et son habitat 90% de savoir c'est le
savoir traditionnel que nos aînés que
que mes amis mes frères m'ont montré
m'ont appris que j'utilise beaucoup là
dessus mais il ya aussi le niveau
technologique oc c'est pour ça qu'on
travaille là-dessus aujourd'hui c'est de
faire des suivis caribou avec des
nouvelles technologies lui c'est
jean-luc canapé de la communauté innu de
pessamit
il est agent de recherche pour cette
étude sur le caribou un animal qu'il
côtoie depuis qu'il est tout jeune
c'est un animal qu'on depuis des années
des années même des siècles
qu'on a survécu grâce à lui nous a
nourris nous a habillé et nous avons
outillés
mais aujourd'hui le caribou est en péril
le faible taux de survie défend
préoccupe les biologistes du ministère
des forêts de la faune et des parcs
grâce à sa connaissance du terrain et du
caribou jean-luc veut contribuer aux
efforts du ministère pour mieux
connaître l'état des populations et de
leur habitat
j'ai un petit fils j'aimerais ça qu'il
voit ou lui aussi donné pour son jeu
mais du score là d'un beau la protection
et le pour aider c'est un animal la
survie
[Musique]
créée on va faire des recherches au
niveau de terrain de deux sites de mise
bas
c'est ici en pleine forêt boréale que
jean-luc guidera son équipe et ce
secteur il le connaît
3 et 6 et une autre qu'on utilise
beaucoup pour aller sur le big one le
pipe - gagnent c'est un secteur du
territoire ancestral de la première
nation innu un immense territoire que
jean-luc appelle sa première maison son
hit à sinan
c'est le territoire familiale oui c'est
un territoire que ma jeunesse que qu'on
utilise cambon châssis contrat pis si
les grands pas rattraper ici on savoir
plus le secteur jean-luc donne quelques
indications péri avant de procéder aux
premiers tests de leur nouvel outil de
travail
marie-hélène rousseau et la responsable
de tout ce déploiement
quand une recherche scientifique souvent
tu vas l'identifier fait un élément
précis que tu veux réponse à ton
hypothèse donc tu vas chercher une
information qui occupa nécessairement
toutes les autres éléments qui se passe
autour
mais jean-luc lui c'est ça qui est
capable dé voir ces éléments à l'appui
d'expliquer le pourquoi tu sais qu'on a
identifié un individu ou pourquoi qui
avait pas beaucoup de fond dans le
groupe on fait un résumé des
observations ne va pas fuir et estime à
combien peu près le nombre d'individus
observés sur le russe sur le web car
c'est au tour
je dirais entre 40 à 50 caribou
probablement autorités
fait sauf que témoin comme non
autochtone j'ai pas le lien culturel que
jean luc tu peux avoir face à l' espèce
protégée le caribou qui est une espèce
aussi parapluie ses protégés plusieurs
autres espèces ses protégés tout un
écosystème
j'ai envie de pratiquer à l'installer et
bien sûr d'accord c'est le projet
[Musique]
en fait ce qu'on veut c'est aller
valider les connaissances
traditionnelles qu'on est déjà acquise
sur l'occupation l'utilisation du
territoire donc avec cet outil leur sont
arrivés à les identifier et les potagers
maintien on fait vraiment un gain ne
pourra la protection de l'espèce
ses connaissances traditionnelles dont
nous par l'ingénieur forestière vont
éclairer les chercheurs par exemple sur
la population des espèces et leur
comportement sur la localisation des
habitats et leur altération et sur des
pratiques alternatives pour rétablir les
équilibres des écosystèmes forestiers
je fais jean françois boucher dirige une
équipe de chercheurs à l'université du
québec à chicoutimi
il s'intéresse à l'étude de la forêt
boréale et ses ressources pour lui aussi
l' expertise des premières nations
deviennent incontournables
une information qui peut être vos est
encore meilleur que n'importe quelle
télé dictacteur on va mettre en place
pour un site comprend des déplacements
parce que il ya une connaissance des
déplacements des animaux qui ont les
autochtones qu'on ne pourrait pas avoir
autrement
jean françois boucher estime toutefois
qu'il y encore beaucoup à faire dans les
milieux scientifiques pour favoriser
l'intégration du savoir autochtone à
celui des sciences
moi je rêve dans un monde idéal d'une
équipe de recherche qui va sur le
terrain puis qui se donne comme concept
comme approche science-fiction veut dire
comme ça une approche scientifique
rigoureuse d'arriver sur un terrain puis
d'avoir toujours quelqu'un qui est la
connaissance traditionnelle du
territoire présent donc il faut que ça
augmente
il faut trouver les occasions que ça
puisse avoir lieu une étude de
l'université de la colombie britannique
révèle que la biodiversité serait plus
abondantes dans les forêts gérées par
les communautés autochtones
[Musique]
le soir venu
jean luc et son équipe se retrouvent
pour préparer la phase nocturne de
l'expérimentation de leur nouvel outil
de travail
[Musique]
jean landry suppôts loin là on a brossé
les dents tout chez que
il y avait déjà une île où si tu vas
bon on va les faire d'autres vols
[Musique]
je souhaite qu'on voit l'animal peut
importe l'animal j'ai mon premier mois
mais de nuit avec ce cette machine
ce vol de nuit conclu la première étape
de ce projet de collaboration entre eux
et nous et scientifique
d'ici quelques années l'équipe soit
faire reconnaître certaines zones à
protéger sur ce territoire en plus de
valoriser le savoir traditionnel
autochtone dans la gestion de nos forêts
quand jean lieu qui rentre dans mon
bureau puis qui vient s'asseoir pour me
parler me faire le dénombrement de ses
observations tout ça c'est pas juste un
nombre qu'il dit c'est vraiment télé
relation qui peut y avoir aussi avec le
loup sur le terrain est ce qu'ils ont
observé des des ravages à quel moment le
caribou est sorti du bois fait que ça
l'amène dramane richir sino à
l'information qu'on peut aller chercher
donc il faut faire cette cette
conversation aulas en les incluant tous
notamment mais aussi ceux qui se taisent
plus souvent qu'autrement ou qu'on a
voulu taire plus souvent qu'autrement
historiquement notamment des autochtones
nous sommes prêts nous sommes prêts en
tant qu et nous en tant que autochtones
oui de partage et de travailler ensemble
- je ne crois